the clark county school district
reporting a confirmed case of monkey pox
at pale verde high school that's right
the principal there sending a message to
all parents today sasha loftus joins us
live from the school in summerlin and
sasha what have you found out
kirsten and christian were told this
note was sent out earlier today as you
mentioned by the principal this
afternoon saying that someone here on
palo verde high school grounds had been
diagnosed with monkey pox now no word on
whether it was a teacher or a student
this is the first reported case within
ccsd as of today 75 probable and
confirmed cases of monkey pox have been
recorded in all of southern nevada this
also comes a few weeks after the
southern nevada health district
announced that monkey pox was found in
our city's waste water the virus spreads
through close physical contact with
someone who's infected and ccsd says
it's not something that normally spreads
in a classroom setting the district says
it is currently working with the
southern nevada health district as they
determine if anyone else may need
further evaluation they said if anyone
does they will of course contact
families contact students and parents to
let them know we will of course continue
following this story all night long as
it continues to develop we're talking to
parents and talking to experts to get
more on this so stay with eight news now
for the latest reporting live tonight
sasha loftis 8 news now